absolument pas j'en ai entendu parler
mais il n'y a pas eu de il n'y a pas eu
d'appel sur dijon
[Musique]
c'est nous qui forme les futures
générations c'est aussi importante de
dents par les deux d'être au courant de
tout ça donc je pense que ça pourrait se
faire et ça devrait se la péter en
danger actuellement et ça pourrait être
pas mal de faire ça mais ça suivra pas
selon amy suivante bah je pense a pas
besoin de grand chose de pas d'un coup
s'est mobilisée je pense que bien
évidemment il ya urgence en ce moment
mais en revanche est ce que c'est bien
utile de sécher les cours dans venir à à
se priver de sa scolarité
après c'est certes un bon moyen
d'interpeller les gouvernements ça c'est
important talent pour que de marcher
pour le climat mais le plus important
c'est pourquoi m aujourd'hui on est
aujourd'hui après plus tard je sais pas
peut-être que je regretterai ce que j'ai
entendu des pétitions je pense que c'est
intéressant et aussi des démarches
que vraiment rassembler un maximum de
monde pour s'affirmer et montré au
gouvernement
ce qu'on souhaite
ce sont des lycéens lycées qui a s'est
engagé dans l'écologie ça on a des échos
ambassadeur on a des des événements qui
sont organisées à pour ramasser les
déchets pour extérieur et du coup je
pense que oui on peut on peut s'engager
si on veut autrement en s'impliquant
dans le district se présentent des dons
caritatifs au lycée ça pourrait être pas
mal
chacun donne ce qu'il veut pour une
association là dessus ou peut-être une
fois ou deux faire une marche un défilé
je trouve que notre génération
s'intéresse beaucoup plus ce climat que
les générations précédentes
il ya beaucoup moins fiable on sera
peut-être pas encore font que ça peut
impacter notre avis on est tous en
danger